[ Cheers and applause ]
-Let's get to the news.
The House voted last week
to pass legislation
protecting same-sex marriages,
because everyone deserves
the right to be
secretly unhappy.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new report,
the Biden administration
isn't worried
about Elon Musk's
ownership of Twitter
and doesn't view the platform
as being a vital part
of its political strategy.
Said Biden, "The future of
campaigning is buttons."
[ Laughter ]
According to a new poll,
37% of Republicans say
they don't want
former President Trump
to run in 2024,
so Trump's gonna take that hint
and just continue to run
for 2020.
[ Laughter ]
Before announcing
his Senate run,
Republican consultants
reportedly hired a law firm
to compile a 500-page dossier
on Georgia Senate candidate
Herschel Walker.
It was just
the names of his kids.
[ Laughter, audience "ohhs" ]
Oh, sure, now that he lost,
we're all sensitive.
[ Laughter ]
During a speech on Saturday
at the New York Young Republican
Club's annual gala,
Georgia Congresswoman
Marjorie Taylor Greene
complained
about liberal policies
and said, "You can pick up
a butt plug or a dildo
at Target nowadays."
Or more likely,
you go in to buy a dildo
and end up leaving with a
bunch of stuff you didn't need.
[ Laughter ]
That's how they get ya.
"Wait in the car, kids.
I'll be right back."
[ Laughter ]
Arizona Senator Kyrsten Sinema
announced last week
that she's leaving
the Democratic Party
and registering
as an independent
because if there's one thing
she's desperate,
it's for people to think
she's "indie."
[ Laughter ]
That's right,
Arizona Senator Kyrsten Sinema
announced that she's leaving
the Democratic Party.
No word on what kind of party
she's going to.
I'm gonna say a Muppet rave?
[ Laughter ]
The federal government
is set to run out of money
on Friday at midnight.
But it was worth it
for those Taylor Swift tickets.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Chuckles ]
Archaeologists in Florida
believe they've discovered
a shipwreck from the 1800s
in the sand of Daytona Beach.
It's surprising because
normally all you find there
are train wrecks.
[ Laughter ]
"Take this picture.
I promise they'll never use it
in a late-night talk show."
[ Laughter ]
Comedian Dave Chappelle
brought Elon Musk up onstage
during a show last night
in San Francisco.
You mean, San Francisco,
where a bunch of tech people
live?
How did that go?
-Don't say nothing.
-It's like bringing Mel Gibson
onstage at the Apollo.
They don't like you there.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, Bloomberg News
published an op-ed last week
titled "We Have to Talk
About Adolf Hitler,"
which was also
the least-popular song
on the "Encanto" soundtrack.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden today signed
the Respect for Marriage Act
into law.
Respecting marriage?
Wow, he really is
undoing all of Trump's orders.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Los Angeles Mayor Karen Bass
yesterday officially resigned
from the House
of Representatives,
which means she's the only
person in Los Angeles
who doesn't have
at least two gigs.
"Me? I'm a mayor/
congresswoman/waiter."
[ Laughter ]
When asked yesterday
if he would consider
leaving the Democratic Party,
like Arizona
Senator Kyrsten Sinema,
West Virginia Senator
Joe Manchin told reporters,
"I'll look at all
of these things.
I've always looked
at all those things,
but I have no intention
of doing anything right now."
Well, he sounds
like a Democrat to me.
[ Laughter and applause ]
New York Mayor Eric Adams
spoke today
at the National Mathematics
Improvement Project,
but this is sad --
he used the opportunity
to promote division.
[ Laughter ]
Coming around, you guys.
You know what's happening
right now.
You're doing the math
on that joke
and it's working up.
[ Laughter and applause ]
It's adding up.
"The New York Times" yesterday
released its list
of The 93 Most Stylish 'People'
of 2022.
Don't bother asking,
Portia from "White Lotus."
[ Laughter ]
Sam Bankman-Fried,
the disgraced founder
of cryptocurrency exchange FTX,
was arrested yesterday
in the Bahamas.
Oh, they got him, huh?
I can't believe he wasn't able
to blend in.
[ Laughter ]
Who fingered him, the humidity?
HBO tonight debuted
"Pelosi in the House,"
which is a new documentary
about House Speaker
Nancy Pelosi
and not, as I had assumed,
a sitcom on the CW.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new study,
people who use an alarm clock
to wake up
are more tired than people
who wake up naturally.
Though, people who wake up
naturally tend to be more fired.
[ Laughter ]
A cow in Virginia recently
escaped from a trailer
and crashed through the glass
doors of an office --
Oh, sorry,
I read the punch line first.
What's black and white
and red all over?
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Ohhs ]
Another math joke.
[ Laughter ]
And, finally,
according to new research,
taking the erectile dysfunction
drug Viagra
can decrease the risk
of developing
Alzheimer's disease,
which is great,
because there's nothing worse
than getting an erection
and forgetting why.
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Who was here?"
[ Applause ]
The White House invited
thousands of people to gather on
the South Lawn yesterday to
watch President Biden sign
the Respect for Marriage Act
into law, because nothing says
"you have my respect"
like hosting a party
and not letting anyone
into the house.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new report,
President Biden has been venting
to friends and confidantes about
the media's focus on his age.
Said Biden, "Can you believe
this crap, Walter?
How about you, Zeke? Jedediah?
Oh, crap."
[ Laughter ]
"I am old."
President Biden today attended
the U.S.-Africa Business Forum,
but not before his aides
reminded him
several times --
regular handshakes.
[ Laughter ]
In a new documentary about
her tenure in Congress,
House Speaker Nancy Pelosi is
shown talking about
former president Trump, and
says, "He's totally insane."
Wow, he is going to be so
furious when he definitely
watches that documentary on
Nancy Pelosi.
[ Laughter ]
"Oh, Nancy -- I know her."
"Well, this will be fun.
My old friend Nancy.
There's a documentary."
[ Laughter ]
"I love my docs."
After being arrested earlier
in this week in the Bahamas,
disgraced cryptocurrency
exchange co-founder
Sam Bankman-Fried is reportedly
being held in
a prison notorious
for harsh conditions.
For one thing, no conditioner.
[ Laughter ]
In a new interview, North Dakota
Senator Kevin Cramer said that
he is not convinced that
former president Trump
is all in on running again
and added,
"Losing another election could
be very damaging to his pride,
not to mention
the Capitol building."
[ Laughter ]
According to a new survey, 32%
of Gen Z are likely to call in
sick at work
when they're feeling unwell,
which is shocking --
a Gen Z person
making a phone call.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new survey,
13% of Americans believe
that they are worse
than the average person
at recommending gift ideas.
Well, not me.
Nana loved her roller blades.
[ Laughter ]
We had a lot of discussion of
what the picture should be.
Mike Scollins, who wrote
the joke, and is --
I think I can say this --
a terrible person...
[ Laughter ]
...wanted the photo to be
a grandmother in a wheelchair
holding up a pair
of roller blades.
[ Laughter ]
I think the one we went with
actually kind of looks like
she knows what she's doing.
[ Laughter ]
Like, she looks scared like
she's seeing an old boyfriend.
[ Laughter ]
These are the kind of
discussions we have.
Now we'll have
a nice, uplifting holiday.
Hopefully the last joke is
holiday-themed
to sort of clear the palate.
I see you're checking to see
what it is, Baze,
and now you remember.
Let's watch. Oh, no.
And finally,
the adult website PornHub --
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
And finally, the adult website
PornHub announced
yesterday that one of the most
popular search terms for 2022
was a type of Japanese anime.
"It's called hentai,"
said your son way too quickly.
[ Laughter ]
Merry Christmas.
After teasing
a "major announcement"
on his social media
platform Truth Social,
former President Trump
announced today
he is releasing a collection
of digital trading cards.
It's what his doctors are
calling "a new symptom."
[ Laughter ]
That's right,
former President Trump
is releasing a collection
of digital trading cards
that chronicle his
life and career,
like that time he won
the Super Bowl,
or that time he won NASCAR,
or that time he went to
space and didn't need a helmet.
[ Laughter ]
I know, we always thought
he was Forrest Gump,
but apparently he does, too.
[ Laughter ]
First lady, Dr. Jill Biden
has reportedly grown
more enthusiastic
over the last three months
about the possibility
of President Biden
running for a second term.
Anything to put off her
having to deal with
a newly retired guy.
[ As Biden ] Get ready, babe,
because I'm about to
get into model trains
big-time!
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] The Biden
administration announced today
that U.S. households can now
order an additional
eight free at-home COVID tests.
It's the perfect gift for the
person who has everything but
isn't sure if it's the flu,
COVID, or RSV.
[ Laughter ]
The United Nations voted
yesterday to remove Iran
from a panel which promotes
women's rights,
which is kind of like
Arby's being stripped
of its Michelin star.
[ Laughter ]
I think they still have one,
because I think they got
two Michelin stars.
Goldman Sachs is reportedly
considering cutting bonuses
this year for
investment bankers.
As for how they're cutting it --
with baking powder!
All right.
[ Laughter ]
It's not fair to say
all finance guys do cocaine,
just the winners!
[ Laughter ]
Producers yesterday released a
trailer for a new reality series
called "MILF MANOR."
[ Laughter ]
"MILF MANOR?"
You mean Williams-Sonoma?
[ Laughter ]
Isn't that what that's called?
I'm genuinely asking.
And finally, a deer in India
recently got stuck
in an ATM vestibule.
But good luck trying to get
just one buck
out of an ATM.
[ Scattered laughter ]
And that -- and that was how
Brian Donaldson
ruined Christmas.
[ Laughter ]
You guys, that was the
monologue, everybody!